aucun indice nouveau quant au sort de ce
jean jaurès uc phrase notre lutte ne
peut être victorieuse ce dernier
communiqué portera son exécution ou la
libération de pierre laporte
louis fournier bonjour bonjour patrice
vous avez écrit la bible sur ces
événements d'octobre 70
vous avez réédité et c'est intéressant
parce que vous dit au début qu'on a
presque résolu tous les mystères donc
vous êtes de cet avis lock on sait ce
qu'on doit savoir de cette crise de
cette période
ah bah oui dès le début de mon ouvrage
dénonce les complotistes qui pensent
qu'on sait rien ou qu on nous a caché
des choses ou qu'il ya des mystères là
dedans mais depuis c'est le 50 ans que
c'est arrivé là cette crise d'octobre il
ya eu des enquêtes des commission
denquête du travail qui a été fait de
deux journalistes mais les gens comme
vous le qui ont fait un travail
rigoureux et foncer l'essentiel de ce
qui est arrivé alors pour moi il n'y a
pas de mystère
la voiture qui avait servi à
l'enlèvement de le subir la porte il y a
une semaine devant sa demeure de la rue
robitaille à saint lambert a été
formellement identifié
l'épisode de la mort de la porte même
chapeau selon vous il n'y a plus de
mystère
on le sait parce qu'il ya une
conversation qui a été enregistrée
illégalement par la sûreté du québec en
janvier
71 entre un avocat maître robert lemieux
et son client jacques roth et maître
jean françois duchesne qui a enquêté sur
ces événements ont pu écouter cette
conversation est maître du chien
explique dans son rapport déjà il ya
quarante ans que c'est arrivé de façon
non prémédité accidentelle ses
ravisseurs voulaient amené monsieur
laporte à l'hôpital le plus proche c'est
à dire celui de greenfield park à
l'époque il s'était blessé la veille
on sait en voulant s'évader en se
précipitant à travers une fenêtre
entre-temps monsieur laporte a fait une
crise d'agitation très violente
il était très affaiblie alors ce qu'il a
fait c'était de crier il s'est mis à
crier très fort de telle sorte que vous
pouvez alerté le voisinage les maisons
étaient très proches les unes des autres
sur la rue à me semble alors un ses
ravisseurs a voulu le maîtriser pour
l'empêcher de crier
et cela porte portèrent gros chandails
de laine à col roulé et en dessous il y
avait une chaînette comme beaucoup de
gens portés à l'époque avec une médaille
scapulaire et son ravisseur afin de
torsion derrière et ça a duré un certain
nombre de secondes on le suit dans le
rapport du coroner en chef
combien tu as et quand il a relâché sa
prise savais pas qu'il y avait une
chaînette en dessous
monsieur laporte était et heymans est
arrivé aussi aussi bête max et j'imagine
qu'ils ont été horrifié de voir ce
qu'ils avaient fait français si mal
raconte dans son livre il est même
tabarnak
qu'est ce qu'on a fait c'est
épouvantable vous même dans votre livre
vous appeler un chat un chat vous dites
un assassinat même si up
même si les circonstances sont complexes
d'un assassinat c'est du terrorisme et
au nom d'une cause qui était
l'indépendance du québec
je dis que c'était une version
québécoise de ce qui existait aussi au
plan international dans les années 60
ça a été des années où il y avait du
terrorisme partout et il le terrorisme
il faut l'expliquer et celui qui l'a
expliqué lemieux je le cite dans mon
livre plusieurs reprises c'est monsieur
rené lévesque et l'asie le terroriste
qu'il faut
et ça c'est incontestable mettre hors
d'état de nuire le plus vite possible
est en quelque sorte le symptôme vivant
d'une maladie qui n'en est pas la cause
alors il y avait donc une maladie à
l'époque dans les années 60 le québec
était une nation opprimée et là vous dit
quelque chose d'intéressant que à ce
terrorisme que la réponse a été
disproportionnée
on a fait croire à une insurrection
appréhendée qui n'existait pas en fait
il n'y avait pas d' insurrection
appréhendée
on l'a su même assez rapidement là c'est
un prétexte qui a été invoqué par ce
qu'ils savaient pas de quelle façon ils
pourraient marquer cette espèce de
sympathie populaire qui commençait à se
manifester aussi à l'époque
est-ce que ce pensionnat de la présence
des militaires dans les rues de montréal
[Musique]
il ya 497 personnes arrêtées la plupart
la grande grande majorité était
totalement innocent
quel regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur
cette période moi j'ai écrit dans mon
livre que c'était ce qui est arrivé au
québec
c'était digne des régimes totalitaires
ce qui s'est passé pendant trois mois la
suspension des libertés civiles vous
pouvez arrêter des gens sans mandat les
détenir jusqu'à trois semaines sans
porter d'accusation et il ya eu près de
36000 perquisitions et des raids chez
des gens c'est énorme ça
entre temps oui des gants plus 17
louis fournier il ya encore des gens qui
disent que tout ça a été téléguidée
infiltrés d'abord est téléguidée par le
gouvernement fédéral qu'on a manipulé
ces jeunes là pour créer ces conditions
là pour ensuite arriver avec une riposte
mais ces gens là n'étaient pas des
marionnettes sans le savoir du fédéral
produit pas du tout le fait que c'est un
mouvement révolutionnaire il a été
infiltré à partir après la crise
d'octobre
il ya eu deux fausses cellules qui ont
été créés et de plus en plus d'effectuer
est infiltré mais avant la crise
d'octobre c'était pas un mouvement qui
était né à filtrer par la police ni
téléguidé par le gouvernement d'ottawa
n'est tout ce qu'on peut lire vous avez
eu un rôle actif dans cette recette pack
journal et skate
vous avez un rôle actif vous avez lu
parce qu'on à l'image de montreuil à la
télé qu'il le fameux committee pour des
raisons humanitaires qui apparaissent
évidents aperçu des développements des
derniers jours
et afin de sauver si possible la vie de
l'attaché commercial de grande bretagne
monsieur james riches grâce nous faisons
lecture intégrale du manifeste du front
de libération du québec
vous avez lu le communiqué du flq à la
radio tu as quel état d'esprit vous et
cheap quand vous pensez à ça aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous mais moi j'étais
simple journaliste j'avais 25 ans j'ai
été assez cassé depuis deux ans et un
soir j'ai reçu par taxi chez moi chez
moi deux documents un communiqué puis un
manifeste parce qu'ils avaient été
interceptés par la police la veille
car monsieur michaud chat mais les
affaires étrangères dit à la télé on va
le diffuser à radio-canada le lendemain
la mes patrons dit on va discuter
le front de libération du québec ne se
laissera jamais dislaire par les miettes
électorale que les capitalistes anglo
saxons lance dans la basse-cour
québécoise à tous les quatre ans et
c'est ce qui a fait que je me suis fait
arrêter par la police deux jours plus
tard je me rappellerai toute ma vie
parce que c'est ça m'a tellement marqué
bien des policiers qui sont présentés
chez moi ils étaient munis d'un mandat
de perquisition vers balmont il dit en
autres perquisitions et d'arrestations
mais vous aviez l époque de la sympathie
pour cette cause comme beaucoup de
québécois j'étais pas militant j'étais
journaliste donc c'est complexe
gg du ca avec une certaine sympathie
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de gens qui
était sympathisant du flq s'en sent
évidemment accepté ce moyen là j'étais
contre la violence absolument
mais il y avait une description de la
situation au québec qui rejoint lé jean
louis fournier un petit mot en terminant
sur rené lévesque leurs gestes jusqu'ici
n'a fait que du mal à tout le monde et
pas seulement aux otages et leurs
proches et aussi que s'il persiste et
que d'autres continuent à leur emboîter
le pas il n'en découlera qu'un temps
d'épreuves plus long et plus cruelle
pour le québec
il a été extrêmement durs envers tout ce
mouvement là racontez moi comment vous
avez perçu cette relation de l'évêque
avec le flq
c'est monsieur lévesque qui a mis fin à
l'action devait effectuer mon jeune quoi
beaucoup le seul vrai que toujours dit
il faut faire ça de façon démocratique
l'indépendance du québec le pq étudiants
76 6 ans après la crise finalement je
pense que on a vu que la seule solution
démocratique s'était pas le flq c'est
évidemment parti québécois la seule voie
possible est la démocratie
absolument
ou fourni merci beaucoup